monsieur le préfet messieurs les
présidents vice-présidents
bonsoir alors moi je suis très heureuse
d'être avec vous cet après midi parce
que ça vous à vous avez en tout cas
l'opportunité de d'évoquer les
problématiques que vous rencontrez
notamment les pêcheurs notamment
également la cause est maire
et je crois que c'est important c'est
vrai que je vous accompagne souvent ce
qui concerne les pêcheurs c'est une
vraie plume problématique et j'espère
qu'on va arriver à trouver des solutions
pour que puissiez exercer votre
profession c'est vrai comme l'a rappelé
mon collègue philippe folliot à chaque
audition puisqu'il s'agit de la place
des outre-mer dans la stratégie maritime
nationale j'évoque toujours là problème
votre problématique 1 et philippe vient
d'en parler enfin tout cas il a posé la
question et je te remercie philippe
puisque aujourd'hui nous avons quand
même l'état qui a représenté par
monsieur le préfet donc je pense que
monsieur le préfet apportera des
éléments de réponses concernant tout ce
qui est agression et tout ce qui est
illégal donc messieurs si vous avez des
réponses vous avez des propositions
faites la fête l'est parce que ce
document de la délégation sénatoriale
outre-mer va être remis au gouvernement
on nous dise yonne pas tout simplement
pour faire plaisir mais c'est parce
qu'il y aura des suites et je vous
demande en tout cas d'être franc et
direct comme d'habitude lorsqu'on se
retrouve voilà merci voyez bien vous le
dire vous même
monsieur le préfet ils sont agressifs
vous imaginez que vous les da en haut
ils sont agressifs envers vous vous
imaginez nos pêcheurs qu'est-ce-qui
suffisant mais
ils sont obligés de parler sur leurs
zones de pêche aujourd'hui là où il ya
du poisson ils n'y vont plus parce que
ces bateaux là sont là du tout ce que de
tous les arguments que chacun emmène on
sait qu'il ya un problème sinon serait
pas là aujourd'hui à ceux
autour de lui dans cette vie que
visioconférence quel que soit on sait
que la pêche illégale malgré l'effort
que fait de l'état elle est toujours
présent et cette année 2021 été la pire
depuis 15 20 ans il ya une chute grâce 2
du poisson débarqué de la production de
départ qui que ce soit en poissons
crevettes ou on vivaneau il ya un choc
terrible aujourd'hui
la pêche illégale qui est pour beaucoup
aussi dans cette affaire donc enfin je
parle pas le nombre de jours de mer
qu'importe le nombre de jours de mer que
l'on pourrait aujourd'hui donné que ce
soit par l'état et par les
professionnels force est de constater
que la pêche illégale et nous avons
commencé un dialogue moi ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que qu'on m'arrête un
petit peu sur des mesurettes comprend
depuis 20 ans sur la sur la pêche il est
illégal il en va de la survie même du
secteur de la pêche il en va aussi de la
souveraineté alimentaire et de la guyane
déjà qu'on ne produit rien bientôt on
mangera rien du tout matin il faut
changer de logiciel là dessus et puis il
faudrait que on arrive tous ensemble à
faire avancer notre territoire